A Sheba Global tested today at 7.9 and I'm scheduled for surgery in three weeks.
They want to bring up my Heba Global either with a blood transfusion or supplementation.
I know cancer cells can feed on iron, what would we recommend?
I would recommend, if your Heba Global is 7.9, there's the fastest way to raise Heba Global
is a blood transfusion.
I mean, there's just that is there's just no substitute for that.
So I would recommend that that will raise it up.
That would because you're getting the influx of blood,
you're not really feeding the cancer with that either.
And yes, iron can feed cancer.
If your Heba Global was at a point where they would not give you a blood transfusion,
let's say it's 8.3 and their cutoff is 8.0.
Different hospitals, different clinics have different cutoffs.
So if they are willing to give you a blood transfusion, I would definitely go with that.
So it's going to raise your Heba Global.
Most rapidly, you'll feel a lot better, you'll be prepped for the surgery.